all right let's uh take a look at the
mess that I've made hello guys my name
is Archana welcome back to another video
today we're gonna be taking a look at a
bit of a post-mortem bit of a
self-reflection and code analysis you
want to call it that of the game that I
made in an hour using my engine hazel so
if you guys haven't seen that video I'll
have it linked like in the top you know
corner or whatever and I'll and in the
description as well basically I made a
game in an hour it was supposed to be
something that was kind of a learning
exercise for hazel and also I guess
something to help us understand what
exactly the engine needs I mean the
engine needs a lot of things that was
pretty clear but still it's really good
too even at a very early stage in the
engines development to kind of sit down
and be like alright I'm gonna make a
game in an hour
using the engine well and ours a bit
extreme obviously had to make the video
interesting but in general just sitting
down maybe spending a day or two just
trying to make a very simple game so in
this case it was kind of like a little
flappy bird clone made by this guy
called Danny and I basically just set
out to completely copy that in my own
engine and see what I could do so that
was good because I didn't need to think
about any ideas and I could take an
existing product that someone had
actually made inside a game engine in
this case unity and actually trying to
recreate it and obviously because it was
something that was actually made in a
game engine like unity which has things
like you know post-processing and like
particle effects and collision detection
and all of this kind of stuff it was
really you know it was clearly made with
technology that was capable of being
called a game engine and capable of
actually making a game like this so it's
good to kind of take that and try and
make it in your own primitive engine and
in fact like I've talked about this
before in other videos but it's super
important to actually use a game engine
like unity if you're building a game
engine yourself you know if you're all
like a game mentioned purus you're like
now I've got my own engine and I want to
use anything else like that's not really
a good approach
I mean sure like you do no one's telling
you to ship a game using unity or
whatever if you don't want to but if you
are building a game engine it makes
sense to take a look at other game
engines if I'm producing a song or I'm
trying to like write a records arms into
audio these days but if I'm if I'm like
producing a song
something like that and I'm gonna
reference I'm not like listening to
what's out there or how other you know
stuff that I like is produced like that
doesn't make much sense does it so the
same time that comes up with game
engines you know if you are trying to
build a good a good game engine you need
to see other successful products like
unity and unreal and the cool thing is
like you'll see issues with them as well
don't be like you know I need to copy
them entirely like no even those and
even those engines themselves will have
issues because again they're trying to
be really journalists for your specific
game for your specific use case they're
probably not going to be ideal at all so
it's good to kind of take that and and
actually dissect it and see what's up so
that's kind of what I did in a way I
mean I didn't use unity myself for this
specific project but I was able to take
something that was made in unity and
then try and recreate it in my own
engine and see what that path would look
like okay so anyway today let's take a
look at a bit of a reflection on what on
earth the code I wrote and to be fair
the whole game was about I think two and
a half hours it took me because the base
game I did make in about an hour but
because hazel doesn't have a lot of
things I had to add in a whole bunch of
systems whole bunch of engine side
systems really I did them in the client
side but engine side systems like
particle systems and like I had to what
I what collision was a big one I think
but um I had to like hack the UI for the
score and stuff using I'm GUI
there are a few things that would weigh
less than ideal that I had to do and
that was as a result of hazel just not
being like not having those features yet
so that really slowed me down and
because of that I kind of had to UM take
longer than than the hour but I guess
the goal with this as well as to take
this and be like okay well we now know
what hazel needs less kind of maybe work
towards a version of hazel where early
would take an hour to make that specific
game with all of the effects and
everything right that's kind of the goal
and that's cool that we have that goal
now as a result of taking that time to
actually make a game that's why I keep
saying it's so important to do something
like that but anyway I guess I'll just
get into this so we'll take a look at
the code in a minute
I just want to give you my thoughts to
begin with now this was like this was
about two weeks ago that I did this so
unfortunately I didn't have
to record this video like almost two
weeks ago while it was still fresh in my
mind so it's been a while I mean
ultimately ultimately I think the
experience was about the same as what I
expected I didn't I you know I mean I
watched the video first as you guys saw
in that video right
I watched Danny's video first and I kind
of took nards and I knew that like you
know hazel doesn't have collision he
delivers n't have a particle system
hazel can't do like post-processing
bloom or anything like that right how we
gonna do all of this stuff I knew that
it would be a little bit rough but that
being said obviously it was a simple
game like he could have done a lot more
like a lot more advanced things
obviously not saying that's relevant to
the game designer all I'm just thinking
like tech technically like on a
technical level you know it's not hard
to easily drop stuff into unity that
would make it almost impossible to
achieve in hazel within like a very
small amount of time because we would
have to write the rest of the engine but
in general luckily it was kind of really
down scale it was kind of easy and
because of that we were able to add
things like the particle system you know
in like I think I wrote the particle
system in about half an hour maybe
because it's it was just quads like
there weren't even textured right we
didn't have to deal with that it was
super easy to do so I think that kind of
played to the benefit in general like I
set out to I think my first kind of my
first thoughts were like okay well let's
get the the player right let's get the
player and the controls working and like
that's kind of step one once we've got
the player and the controls and I can
hit spacebar but that kind of you know
physics I mean again I didn't really
have physics like in his version he had
the game actually but when the player
ship collided with like you know the
triangle like it would kind of like
slide down it and you had that actual
you know actual physics which you know
we could out obviously using box2d in
the future in hazel that's probably what
I would do however you know for this
version I just used a very simple kind
of you know velocity I guess modern or
you call it but basically what we just
have like we have the player's position
we have a velocity and the players
position we always add the velocity
times a delta time every frame into that
actual
like player position and the velocity
will either the velocity can increase
and decrease based on gravity and based
on player input so that's kind of that's
kind of what we what we did which was
fairly simple and straightforward to
setup and then once I had to play being
able to be controlled and I loaded in a
texture for that obviously and made sure
that I could rotate the player which I
had to extend the engine code to do
after that I was able to just simply
create like star creating a level around
the player and that's what I did and
then once we have the level and we had
the random generation which also is
quite simple to do for this game you
know I created a triangle texture for
all of the pillar positions that my
cauldron pillars but there's kind of
triangle the level terrain I guess
because hazel doesn't render triangles
but specifically the reason why I
actually created a triangle texture
instead of going ahead and you know
actually just adding a draw triangle
function into hazel because it's really
easy to draw a triangle obviously like
you know if in jail you just you know
what we're rendering two triangles
that's what a quad is but the reason I
did that was because I knew that I was
going to want to add that bloom effect
that glow effect and that was something
that clearly I was gonna have to just do
in Photoshop as a texture because hazel
doesn't have breast post-processing
hazel doesn't have any of that stuff at
all so because of that I kind of went
the texture route which obviously
presents another problem which is like
to do with collision boundaries and
stuff which I also had to add in which
was probably the pot the toothed longest
and was the most annoying it wasn't like
that annoying but it's just not ideal
anyway I think we should just jump into
the card because I'm I'm sending up that
I'm explaining the code anyway it's
gonna be easier if I actually show it so
let's just take a look at what we got
here
okay so I thought that we should
probably start at the beginning so this
is where the application actually starts
we have this created application
function that we implement in the client
side this is inside the sandbox app file
here and basically all this does is it
returns new sandbox which is this class
which is a hazel application and then
the only thing that really does is
pushes this game layer onto the layer
stack so if you need a hazel and you
don't show what layers are I recommend
that you check out the cabbage in Syria
specifically the episode on layers
because that explains it pretty well but
basically
is just something that will receive
updates and from the game loop so in
other words you can see this layer on
update with the time step this happens
every single application loop and also
it will receive events here in reverse
order of the actual layer stack so in
other words you probably have like a
layer for your actual game maybe a layer
for debug UI or something like that or
just regular UI on top of that stuff
that is maybe clickable so that it
doesn't interfere with your game logic
or anything like that that's kind of the
idea for this game obviously really
simple we just have one layer because we
have an hour at the whole game nothing
too fancy at all so inside the game way
the first thing that runs is of course
the constructor first thing we're doing
here is creating the camera so the
reason I'm doing this is because okay um
I'm arbitrarily picking an orthographic
camera with here at 8 and again this
basically just means that well actually
it's the width the total width is 16
because we're doing negative cam with
two top cam width and in fact that's the
camera high or not the width but anyway
what this is doing is we're basically
setting up our units in a way right so
we're saying that this is these are the
orthographic camera bounce so relative
to these units is going to be the size
of everything else we ran to us so in
other words if I you know if I know that
from top to bottom you know we're
dealing with like 16 units right then I
might make my player 1 by 1 unit because
that way it would kind of be like 1/16
of the entire vertical space that we
have if I had made this like 80 instead
of 8 then it might make more sense for
the player to be 10 by 10 units big
right so this is all kind of arbitrary
and relevant it will rather relative to
this specific like orthographic
projection that you set up and I think I
actually started with 10 but then I
reduced a day when we wanted the camera
to kind of follow the player and soon be
able to play it more and then the reason
I made this like into a function is
because on window resize when we resize
the window we want to be able to
actually recreate the camera because the
aspect ratio might have changed so we
need to kind of take that into
consideration otherwise we'll get you
know distorted graphics and then we
initialize this random class that I
quickly droids it is basically just
using like
it was 11 I guess that kind of random
number generation engine that they
provide which is this one over here and
then basically we're just setting it in
the beginning and then I think we're
creating a distribution with nor actual
because you can provide a bounds for
this distribution but I'm just saying
you know no bounds that also it'll go up
to I think the maximum value of a UN 32
T which is like 4.2 billion and then
what so what that's doing is this is
generating a number between like zero
and 4.2 billion and then what we're
doing is dividing it by that maximum
numerical limit offer UN 32 T so we're
getting basically a value between 0 and
1 a float between 0 and 1 and this is
really useful because we can take this
float and we can this is between 0 & 1
you know we can multiply it with any
number we want and we kind of get a
random number between those bounds if
that makes sense so in other words if I
multiply this with 50 then I'll get a
number from 0 all the way up to 50 based
on you know what the float is so if it
generates 0.5 and that will be you know
25 so that's kind of really powerful and
lets us do something like that really
easily without having to like specify
parameters that are like I want a random
number between these bounds or whatever
and you'll see that in use in the level
class a bit later on as well okay anyway
I think I might go through is a bit
quicker because this is gonna take
forever if I just do it this way
you know I'm initiating initializing
this level class here I think that I I
mean these are all kind of these are all
kind of this level is like entirely on
the stack and everything so I can't do
anything in the constructor because it
gets default constructed I think
immediately you know either that or I'd
have to like initialize it here but by
just having this init function I'm kind
of bypassing that in a way and saying
that well actually I want you to
initialize it here because we need to
load like textures and stuff and we want
opengl to already been like created it
at this point and by creating them
specifically referred to the context all
right sir loading our triangle texture
which is the level kind of building
blocks so this is the one that
eventually you know we let's say
triangle this is the one that eventually
we added the glory to soar there's no
other background
grand studio and wanting to make it
green for some reason but you can seem
about that kind of glow effect on it
which looks quite nice
alright so we're letting in that texture
then we're loading in the players assets
which is really just the shift texture
so we're getting all that out of the way
once when we attach our game layout and
then we're just setting up a new font as
well this is just the open sans font
beside 120 which I just got from github
this is the airport font here and then I
think that's about it so from there well
I mean the player yeah that's actually
it I think level and it probably doesn't
do anything else well yeah it does the
pillar generation so this is us creating
the pillars not sure what okay so the
way that I structured this is we
basically have this is kind of
interesting you talk about I'm gonna
probably revert to talking about more
complicated parts of this because
otherwise I'm serious is gonna be like
two hours long I could talk about this
for two hours but uh no I don't think
anyone wants that so basically we have
five pillars right and I just closed
level so that's great we have five
pillars that's all we deal with right we
have emperors resize five this happens
in the initialization of the level right
so once and that's all we're dealing
with it because well we the game is the
game can potentially go on forever and
there's no way that we can just keep you
know adding more and more pillars so we
don't need to we can't see more than
five sets of pillars on the screen at
one time and by sets I just mean the top
and and the bottom one we can't see more
than five time anyway so let's always
just have a maximum of five and then
we'll just recycle them when we get to
the end you know we'll take that first
one and we'll add it to the front again
and we'll kind of keep going that way
until we well it'll just keep going
forever which is nice so what we're
doing here is there's two parameters for
this create pillar function there's the
index which is the index into that
vector into this pillars vector that is
actually going to create the pillar art
and then we have an offset which is just
a horizontal offset into the level so
this is the actual level position of the
pillar so the position of the pillar
inside the level so top and bottom
position X specifically there's top
there's top and
for most of these things the top is the
top pillars the top triangle and then
the bottom is the bottom triangle and
then all we're doing here is we're
basically saying that okay well X the X
is going to be whatever the horizontal
offset is so in this case you can say
because I'm creating the first five
pillars of the entire level I'm
basically just saying that it's gonna be
I times ten so in other words we'll have
one pillar at zero 10 20 30 40 and that
well that's it 0 10 20 30 40 okay we
have five pillars those are the
horizontal those are the expositions and
then for the Z position so this is a bit
tricky the reason is we need these two
Renda we need these to blend with each
other well right if they have the same
set index then when they get rented they
might get rented that when the depth
testing happens and the blending happens
inside OpenGL inside out actually what
GPU rendering it's it might potentially
render the pillars in the wrong order
not really rendered them in the wrong
order but because of their Zed values
when it comes time to blend them
together it's not gonna know if
something is in front or behind and it's
not gonna be able to blend those pixels
well which means that basically our glow
will be cut off but we want our glow to
smoothly blend together so what I'm
doing here is I'm basically saying that
you know start with and these are
arbitrary values we've set our cameras
projection to be between negative 1 and
1 basically we're just saying that you
know it's start with negative 0.5 based
on the index of the pillar and then you
know incremented by 0.1 so basically we
end up with something from negative 0.5
to positive well just zero I guess and
that's going to be the set position and
because we're doing it kind of from left
to right they end up blending well
together so that's kind of what that is
for it's just so that and you can play
around with this by the way the code you
guys I didn't mention the code for all
of this is on github and there'll be a
link in description below so you can
check this out for yourself and play the
game for yourself but basically you know
this is just here and you can play
around with this and get rid of it for
example and see how like it won't be
correct in fact let me just demonstrate
that right now
run this servlet and it works and
everything but if we do this they're
just not going to blend well together
because they're all gonna be on the same
set value and yeah you'll see what
happens so yes as you see this how it's
cut off that's because this texture goes
to about here and since like they've
rendered on the same thing when it when
did when this gets rented after it has
no idea like you know it's like well do
I blend with these pixels are they
behind me are they in front well
actually they're on the same level as me
so I guess I won't blend with them it
doesn't work out very well but if you
have this then you know those pixels are
not only already in like the depth
buffer and they're already in the color
buffer so that we can blend with them
you can see that that shows up normally
yeah not only are they inside that color
and depth buffer and we can blend with
them but they're you know we know that
the second triangle is in front thus we
should be blending with it so that's
really important to kind of get that
right
okay Centron gap this is just the random
number generation you can see what I'm
doing here random float gives me around
and flow between 0 & 1 I'm multiplying
it by 35 and then spreading half of that
so I basically get a number between
negative 17.5 and positive 17.5 which is
just you know I've identified that's a
good kind of vertical position and then
with the gap as well I'm randomly
calculating a gap which is how far apart
these should be this again some pretty
basic math just a position top and
bottom P low relative to that kind of
gap and to the center so that we can
kind of move them around and that's kind
of that's basically all the level
generation then on update what we have
is based on the player's position we
have this kind of moving pivot target
which is basically and this is important
because this is we know that the pillars
are at every 10 units right so because
of that what we do is we basically
position this pillar target which I
think starts at 30 right so when the
players x position reaches or surpasses
for 30 right when that's when that when
that tips over 30 then we need to create
a new pillar of whatever the pillar
index is which should be the first one
right 0 we're creating a new pillar and
then we're moving the pillar target by
20 units
so now it's 50 right so that next time
that the player will rather know sorry
we're not we're creating the pillar 20
so it's it's way off the screen and then
what we're doing is we're seeing the
we're incrementing the pillar index and
if it goes above pillars size which is 4
it will wrap around and go back to 0 and
then we're just incrementing pillar
target by 10 which means that the next
time the player crosses that boundary we
need to generate another pillar so
that's basically how we keep generating
pillars right we're just we just have a
little target and then when we cross
over the target it's almost like a
little trigger box when we cross over
that trigger box over that target then
we move that trigger box to the next
like between pillars area and then we
just we just create a new pillow
basically at some place that is in the
future kind of off-screen forward in the
positive x-axis okay
so what's next collisions probably
interesting to talk about
so collision the way the collision works
is just thinking maybe I should save
collision for another episode because
there's still so much stuff to get
through and collisions a big one yeah
maybe I'll save the way the collision
works for another episode if you guys
are interested in that just drop a
comment below and I'll make that video
probably a little sooner that way let's
take a look at some more of the graphics
maybe so we have this huge shift effect
so you can see that what happens is this
these colors oh that's a hot one
these colors they just gradually shift
right so they just go through all of the
hues so how are we doing that so the
texture that we have is just this basic
white triangle right that we made inside
Photoshop what we're doing is we're
loading in that texture and then when it
comes time to render that texture which
is when we render our pillars which is
inside here right we go through all of
our pillars and we do a draw what
function here sir and then we're passing
in the triangle texture we're also
passing in a color and that color is
something that we if we go into here we
set that color as a uniform inside our
shader and then when it comes time to
actually issued a tropical and we go
into a shader which is the texture
shared everything you can see we've got
this new color uniform here and then
what we're doing is when we sample the
texture which is over here we're
multiplying it with that color so that's
how we get colors right and because you
know this is obviously a 4 component
color and everything and this color is
all like has an alpha channel and
everything the glow will get multiplied
correctly as well and so we get a
colored triangle as for the actual huge
shift effect that's pretty simple as
well we have this MP la HSV function
here and then what is our variable here
and then what we're doing is this is a
hue saturation and value I guess HSV I
guess I've called it hue saturation and
luminance usually valued HSV well
anxious face fine as well value is just
the luminance then anyway so we have
this kind of we have this variable here
and then what we're doing is the X the X
inside this Effect 3 is just the hue
value between I think is zero and one
yeah between zero and one and then based
on that you know we're actually I think
expanding it to between 0 and 360
because that's the kind of hue this is
something that I've just taken from the
internet which basically would just
converts out our HSV to RGB because we
need to pass an RGB to our shader and
then that's what our color is and then
we render both the floor on the ceiling
and then also all of the pillars with
that kind of color over I so we're just
you know in the update we're just
cycling through those colors here that's
it it's pretty simple the other I guess
graphic C thing to probably talk about
is the actual kind of vignette kind of
lighting things that I've got going on
not really lighting but um you can see
that the corners are kind of darker and
we have this light effect if we disable
that entirely it will look drastically
different so let's go ahead and but darn
multiply it with a distance here dist
then this is what looks like wasn't it
lighting you can see it looks a lot
blonder and probably a lot worse I would
say I'm not the biggest fan of adding
vignette to like everything but in this
case
think for this kind of game and just you
know if there's a little quick game I
guess it does add quite a bit of mood to
it and just makes it look a lot nicer so
that's super simple what I'm doing here
is I have this V screen position varying
rival kind of output from the vertex
shader that I'm setting here which is
basically the it's the GL position so
this will basically be these screen
bounds in I think probably the
normalized device coordinates so between
negative 1 and 1 in X&Y right so
negative 1 being the right side and the
bottom side for Y and then positive 1
being the right sorry I said left side
is what I meant not right side left side
negative 1 right side positive 1 and
then same with top and bottom where top
is positive 1 and bottom is negative 1
so we have that value now and then all
I'm doing here is I'm basically
multiplying while I'm calculating the
distance right this distance function
which is built into GLSL it's just
giving me the distance of two vectors
basically so the distance between this
point which is screen position I'm
multiplying it by 0.8 just to make it a
bit like not as extreme so in other
words instead of negative 1 to 1
it's zero negative zero point eight two
positives are open eight now and then
zero which is the exact center of the
screen and then I'm inversing it so one
minus that because I know it's not gonna
be able of 1 in fact it's not gonna be
above zero point eight but that's not
necessarily true actually because it's
diagonal it'll be more but anyway my
point is I'm inverting it I'm invert I'm
doing the inverse here so that basically
from that center point as we go out
instead of the distance increasing the
distance is decreasing so it kind of
starts at one right if that distance is
zero and then it gradually tapers off to
probably around the zero and then I'm
just clamping it making sure it is
actually in between 0 and 1 just in case
and then I'm doing a so that by itself
gives us a linear fall-off now and if I
get rid of this square root then what
that's doing is basically just again and
I'll just kind of crash here so the
since we're multiplying this distance
value with our
color right if the distance is say zero
or very small we're gonna get black and
then if it's one or a revolt larger than
one with snow it's never gonna because
by clamping it but if it's one which it
will be in the dead center then there's
no change to the color cause we're just
multiplying the color by one and then as
we get further away obviously that value
is decreasing so everything else gets
darker and darker and darker now this is
fine but this kind of fall-off is it's a
linear fall-off and it doesn't look as
good as something that has a bit more of
curve to it so enter square root by
using a little square root fall off you
can see that it falls off a lot slower
so it kind of curves right if I did the
opposite of a square root which would be
just like a square basically so if I say
distance equals distance time distance
this is also a curved fall off but you
can see it has the opposite effect is
the inverse of that it falls off a lot
quicker but we wanted to fall off slower
so that's why I used a square root which
is not the most efficient of things but
it's fun so there we go
so that's how we get that I hopefully
that makes sense hopefully that was
enough detail as to how that actually
works it's yes it's simple it's a very
simple shared a trick nothing too fancy
going on here but you can see it works
pretty well ok cool so that's basically
a lot of the graphic stuff the other
interesting thing is the particle system
but I'm gonna have a separate video just
about basically writing a particle
system in an hour probably and that's
we're just gonna cover a lot a lot of
that in more detail then because this
video is tracking on long enough
but yeah I think that's probably about
it there's not much to it to be honest
there's obviously all this gamestate but
that's you know pretty simple we just
have like three different game states
and based on that we decide you know
what UI to render we decide what you
know if the game set is play then we're
update we update the level otherwise we
don't so in other words when we hit
something in this gamer but you can see
the level stops updating which means
that these particles stop updating and
everything like that but then when we
click on the screen which is inside this
on event function and it's time to this
on my mouse button pressed if the set is
game over and
click it will reset the level all right
so that just resets everything meaning
that we basically set gamma to false we
were set the player which just sets the
player's position back to where it was
and really like resets the velocity as
well then we have pillar target and
pillar index being reset as well to the
default values and then we recreate
those first pillars as the same way that
we did inside level in it and then but
the cool thing is we don't like I
deliberately did this we don't reset the
particles or anything which is quite
cool because if you you'll see that if I
click to play now these particles that
are here they will continue kind of
flying around right so there they are
right which is a really cool effect I
think so fight you know create a bunch
of particles that could still kind of
there which is super cool I could have
just kept updating the particle system
after the player crashes right and then
in that case in that case you know it's
not going so for example let me just
quickly demonstrate that if I just
quickly make the what's the best way to
do this well it's actually inside the
player so let's see play out and then
[Music]
update particles I'll just write it here
particle system on update we need the
time step there which makes sense so
time step what do we need hazel time
step TS okay sir we've got update
particles so let's go into the on update
function and instead of updating the
particle system here what I'm gonna do
that anymore because we're gonna update
it and work and update it here and then
I think level has get player so if we go
back to our game layer and then let's
see where's all this stuff we'll just do
em level get player and then update
particles update particles ts right so
we shouldn't see any difference here but
if the game is actually over our
particles will keep kind of disappearing
so that's that's what should happen
hopefully everything works out so yeah
we have no change here but if I crash
here you can see they just go away as
you would expect right so I don't know I
don't think that looks as cool as if
they just kind of freeze and then that
there the next time you play so anyway
that's that's gonna wrap up this video
hopefully you guys enjoy it let me know
what you thought in the comments below
if I didn't explain something that you
want to see explained let me know I know
there's like the collision stuff that
I'll probably save for like kind of part
two of this episode if you guys are
interested in that and there's also the
particle system which I know so many of
you aren't interested in and I will
I might dissect that but then I also
want to make a video in which I ride a
particle system that's a little bit more
advanced than what we have here like
within an hour basically in show you
guys how to get that up and running and
what in a more efficient way to actually
do that is let me know what your
thoughts are on that in the comment
section below
really just let me know what you want to
see because obviously I'm making these
videos for you guys and you know it's
great that I care about explaining this
particular part of it but if you want to
see something and I'm missing it then
definitely let me know if you enjoyed
the video don't forget to hit the like
button if you new subscribe and I will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]